hey guys it is the 16th of July today my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games but news for those of you
who've been wanting to take your call of
duty skills to space unfortunately it
seems that Activision aren't that keen
on taking the series to the final
frontier call of duty black ops 3
multiplayer director Dan bunting told
GamesRadar I don't think we're ever
going to reach a point where we just
completely ignore finding authenticity
adding that he thinks call of duty needs
to feel believable if you're thinking
about all the futuristic tech in
advanced warfare black ops 3 and
thinking he's full of crap funding
stresses that the technology there is
rooted in reality presumably based on
current experimental military stuff so
the team doesn't consider that tech to
be science fiction he didn't mention
anything about all those zombie modes
however what it walk what is that what
on earth you know it's [ __ ] weird I
don't consider this [ __ ] weird anymore
uncharted the Nathan Drake collection
which is that to arrive on ps4 this fall
will have a new difficulty option and
it's removing those forced motion
controls for those of you who did not
enjoy traversing tree trunks with your
ps3 sixaxis controller in uncharted one
drake's fortune now you won't have to
according to kotaku the game's motion
controls will either be optional or gone
completely from the upcoming collection
you will still be able to switch on the
feature for aiming grenades if you were
keen on that the developer of the
remasters blue point is also adding
another difficulty option for all three
games the dev have said the new
difficulty has been designed to
challenge even the collections QA
testers which presumably means it'll be
even more difficult than this series is
pre-existing crushing difficulty which
only unlocks when you finish the game on
hard finally batman arkham knight for pc
might be out of action until sep tember
of this year kotaku australia reports
that internal documents sent to re be
game stores from Warner Brothers site
that updates for the game will be
released in spring that's Australian
spring which means we might not see
the game fiction back on shelves until
sep tember at the earliest the document
adds quote we have made the difficult
decision to recall all pc stock from
stores to return to the vendor until an
acceptable solution is released a
specific date for release updates has
not been provided by one of others all
rock steady at this time let me know
down in the comments how you feel about
Arkham Knight staying off shelves for
another few months you can add to
gamespot where we've got the latest on a
new brothers in arms game and a new war
home again that is everything I wanted
to tell you about today but do be sure
to join me same time tomorrow for my top
five stories of the whole gaming week I
will catch you them